vor zehn jahren stehen die menschen in
der arabischen welt gegen ihre herrscher
auf der arabische frühling beginnt
jahrzehntelang hatten diktatoren ganze
länder als ihr eigentum betrachtet als
sie ihre macht bedroht sehen schlagen
sie brutal zurück
ein kampf mit ungleichen mitteln beginnt
wir wollen alle das gleiche würde
gerechtigkeit und auf dem tisch marode
regime il kollabieren
das volk klagt die diktatoren davon
träume von einer arabischen welt in der
menschen über ihr schicksal entscheiden
religiöse extremisten greifen nach der
macht statt demokratie wollen sie einen
islamischen staat muslimbrüder gibt es
eigentlich keine alternative zumindest
wenn man sich den kern ihrer ideologie
anschaut zur machtübernahme
kriegel brechen aus
wir haben nur reis und das nicht mal
jeden tag was ist die bilanz des
arabischen frühlings zehn jahre danach
angesichts zahlloser täter und opfer von
krieg und vertreibung ist der arabische
frühling gescheitert
[Musik]
sidi bouzid hat weltgeschichte
geschrieben
in der kleinstadt in der tunesischen
provinz beginnt der arabische frühling
auf dem land weil die situation für
viele arme unter der herrschaft des
langjährigen präsidenten ben ali
unerträglich geworden die armen bauern
müssen täglich ums überleben kämpfen
ihr verdienst von fünf euro am tag
reicht kaum um ihre familien zu ernähren
nur der markt ermöglicht ein auskommen
aber oft genug können sie die
standgebühren nicht bezahlen dann
beschlagnahmt die polizei die wahre ira
willkür sind die händler ausgesetzt
so ging es auch mohammed bouazizi immer
wieder der junge mann träumte von einem
anderen leben berichtet seien kozacka
bouazizi aber dann kam der tag der alles
änderte
der 17 dezember hat der tag der das fass
zum überlaufen gebracht hat
mohammed wurde nicht zum ersten mal von
der polizei beleidigt die beamten
beschlagnahmten nicht zum ersten mal
seine ware um sein recht einzufordern
ging er zum rathaus dort wollte er den
beamten erklären dass er seine familie
versorgen muss aber die bürokraten
wollten ihm nicht zu hören
sie wiesen ihn schon am eingang ab dann
auf einmal zündete er sich an
mohamed bouazizi übergoss sich vor dem
rathaus mit benzin eine verzweiflungstat
die ärzte können ihn nicht mehr retten
nach 18 tagen im koma stirbt er
mohamed bouazizi hatte wie viele seiner
generation keine chance eine sichere
arbeit zu finden er wurde nur 26 jahre
alt sein tod wird die tunesier auf und
wird das signal für die revolution schon
am tag nach bossis selbstverbrennung
gehen die menschen in sidi bouzid auf
die straße
ihre wut richtet sich vor allem gegen
präsident ben ali der das land seit 1987
mit eiserner härte regierte er versprach
den tunesien wohlstand aber seine
familie und seine günstlinge deuteten
das land erbarmungslos aus
immer wieder hatte sich protest gegen
die persönliche bereicherung und
wuchernde korruption geregt ergebnislos
jetzt treibt mohamed bouazizi
selbstverbrennung die menschen in tunis
auf die straßen
das regime ben alis antwortet auf die
proteste mit gewalt
aber es kehrt keine ruhe ein die
demonstranten bleiben hartnäckig
handyvideos von den opfern der
polizeigewalt kursieren in ganz tunesien
die sozialen medien werden zum
brandbeschleuniger des arabischen
frühlings die bloggerin lina ben mhenni
wird zum gesicht der proteste all diese
momente die ich bei den aufständen in
regem cdu sieht in kasserine erlebt habe
sind unauslöschlich in meinem gedächtnis
eingebrannt an eine situation erinnere
ich mich besonders genau
ich war in regiert bei den eltern eines
jungen der gerade erschossen worden war
da saßen seine schwester seine mutter
und sein vater um seine sterblichen
überreste im wohnzimmer die familie will
dass die bloggerin das verbrechen des
ben ali regimes dokumentiert lina ben
mhenni hat schon zuvor kritisch über die
regierung berichtet auf ihrer website
tunesien girl veröffentlicht sie auch
das video von dem toten jungen
viele tunesier vertrauen ihren posts
mehr als den offiziellen nachrichten
sie macht die sozialen medien zu einer
gewaltlosen waffe im kampf gegen das
regime auf facebook dokumentieren sie
und andere aktivisten die opfer der
polizeigewalt
das internet hat alles verändert
man konnte plötzlich viele menschen
erreichen
vorher war es nicht möglich so schnell
zu handeln ereignisse live zu übertragen
videos so schnell zu teilen
das unglaubliche geschieht am 14 januar
2011 verlässt wenn ali das land richtung
saudi arabien tunesien aus allen
schichten vereint im ganzen land zeigen
dass sie stärker als ben ali sind eine
jahrzehntealte diktatur ist hinweggefegt
tunesien ist der ausgangspunkt der
aufstände die innerhalb weniger monate
weite teile der arabischen welt erfassen
ob in algerien jordanien ägypten oder in
bachrain auf der arabischen halbinsel in
syrien oder dem jemen
die menschen gehen auf die straße für
mehr brot mehr sicherheit mehr freiheit
die nachricht vom sturz des tunesischen
diktators ben ali alarmiert den
herrscher ägyptens hosni mubarak 2011 82
jahre alt auch er ist seit jahrzehnten
an der macht sorgsam inszeniert die
parteitage die ihn im amt bestätigen
mubarak regiert das land mit hilfe des
militärs und der geheimdienste die
soziale lage in ägypten ist sogar noch
explosiver als in tunesien etwa ein
viertel der menschen lebt unterhalb der
nationalen armutsgrenze
viele familien sind auf tagelöhner jobs
angewiesen
safran el sayed ist noch student als die
unruhen in tunesien beginnen
ich kann mich sehr gut an den tag
erinnern an dem die revolution in
tunesien begannen wir fuhren zur
tunesischen botschaft in kairo und
riefen zur unterstützung der
demonstranten in tunesien parolen wie
jetzt kommt die revolution und sie wird
das regime vernichten auch parolen gegen
hosni mubarak
was in tunesien geschehe hat uns hoffen
lassen
die revolution in tunesien erfasst man
auch ägypten und treibt die menschen auf
den tahrir platz den platz der befreiung
elf tage nach der flucht ben alis am 25
januar versammeln sich zum ersten mal
tausende menschen um gegen das regime zu
protestieren
der tahrir platz wird zum zentrum des
aufstands
das regime reagiert wie es immer
reagiert hat es schickt seine
schlägertrupps mit gewalt hat mubarak in
der vergangenheit alle proteste im keim
erstickt doch diesmal während sich die
demonstranten
die tunesier haben es vorgemacht die
proteste eskalieren
regierungsgebäude gehen in flammen auf
das regime wankt dann betritt das
militär die bühne
die armeeführung hat früh erkannt dass
mubarak nicht zu retten ist aufgeheizt
der generäle gehen die soldaten nicht
gegen die demonstranten vor
stattdessen verbrüdern sie sich mit
ihnen nahost experte daniel gerlach hält
das militär für den eigentlichen
machtfaktor in ägypten
die wollten sich selber als volksnah und
als letztendlich retter des volkes auch
darstellen und mubarak muss zurücktreten
das militär hat die macht übernommen
und letztendlich hat das militär seinen
alten status bewahren können aber nach
außen den eindruck erweckt wir stehen an
der seite des volkes wir stehen an der
seite der bevölkerung
damit ist das schicksal mubaraks
besiegelt wie in tunesien hat das volk
ein regime zum einsturz gebracht das
unantastbar schien zunächst stellt das
militär eine übergangsregierung doch die
demonstranten fordern freie wahlen
sie träumen von einer demokratischen
zukunft meine persönliche vorstellung
war das eine zivile übergangsregierung
bestimmt wird
die sollte eine neue verfassung
entwickeln und das wichtigste projekt zu
der zeit einen wirtschaftsplan entwerfen
damit es endlich wieder eine
wirtschaftliche perspektive gibt
das alles sollte die übergangsregierung
anstoßen
doch dazu kommt es nicht
in das politische macht vakuum stoßen
ganz andere kräfte die muslimbrüder die
unter mubarak in schach gehalten wurden
jetzt sehen sie ihre chance gekommen die
muslimbrüder sind in ägypten der 1920 er
jahre entstanden im kampf gegen die
britischen kolonialherren 2011 träumen
sie nun von einem staat in dem ein
radikaler islam das sagen hat
muslimbrüder gibt es eigentlich keine
alternative zumindest wenn man sich den
kern ihrer ideologie anschaut so
machtübernahme
denn nur dann das lehren auch die
schriften ihres gründers hassan al banna
ist man eigentlich in der lage gottes
willen und den islam wirklich umzusetzen
nur dann wenn man politische macht in
der hand hat und wenn man den staat
umgestalten und innen und das politische
leben bestimmen kann
in doha der hauptstadt des emirats katar
am persischen golf verfolgen die macht
habe die vorgänge in ägypten mit großem
interesse
katar beherbergt muslimbrüder aus aller
welt und fördert ihren aufstieg die
herrscher familie unterstützt
islamistische gruppen wie die
muslimbrüder mit millionensummen mit dem
ziel diese strategisch für ihre zwecke
nutzen zu können
den einfluss kattas in der arabischen
welt zu vergrößern
1996 gründet der emir den fernsehsender
al jazira als sprachrohr qatars das
medienhaus entwickelt sich dank
staatlicher förderung zum wichtigsten
sender in der arabischsprachigen welt
al jazira erreicht sich millionen
haushalte von marokko bis irak vom jemen
bis zur westbank oder sogar europa der
sender wird während der proteste zu
einer art cnn der arabischen welt die
ganze welt ist live dabei wenn in kairo
oder tunis demonstranten auf die straße
gehen kritiker werfen dem sender jedoch
vor eine eigene agenda zu verfolgen er
bietet den islamisten eine mediale
plattform chefredakteur damals einer der
einflussreichsten arabischen
journalisten
er weist die kritik zurück al jazira sei
ein propaganda organ der muslimbrüder
niemand kann leugnen dass die
bruderschaft im arabischen frühling
aktiv war
sie war aktiv im widerstand gegen hosni
mubarak
gegen ben ali und jedes regime in der
region
das ist also eine politische kraft in
der gesellschaft und wir sind ein
fernsehsender der das abbildet was in
der gesellschaft und in der politik
wichtig ist und deshalb müssen wir die
muslimbruderschaft ebenso zeigen wie wir
jeden zeigen müssen der eine stimme hat
ein star des senders scheich yusuf al
qaradawi über jahrzehnte einer der
führenden ideologen der muslimbrüder
viele jahre hatte al qaradawi eine
eigene show auf al dschasira scharia und
leben auf der er seine sicht des islam
verbreiten konnte der muslimbruder al
qaradawi ruft in seinen predigten die
vom sender regelmäßig übertragen werden
zum kampf gegen die feinde des islam auf
immer wieder ziel seines hasses der
staat israel und seine jüdischen
bewohner der zusammenbruch des regimes
in ägypten ist ganz im sinne al qaradawi
nach jahrzehnten im katarischen exil
sieht er eine gelegenheit zur
machtübernahme durch die muslimbrüder
eine woche nach dem rücktritt hosni
mubaraks haben sich wieder
hunderttausende versammelt für eine
freitagspredigt gehalten von al qaradawi
ausgerechnet auf dem tahrir-platz wo die
ägyptische revolution begonnen hatte
es zeigt sich der islamismus wurde vom
regime mubaraks unterdrückt und bekämpft
aber er ist nie verschwunden 2012 ein
jahr nach dem sturz des präsidenten wird
der repräsentant der muslimbrüder
mohammed mursi zum nachfolger gewählt
nur sie verspricht der präsident aller
ägypter zu sein
mehr jobs mehr wohlstand mehr demokratie
zentrale forderungen des arabischen
frühlings sollen wahr werden
aber das gegenteil geschieht die
radikalen islamisten gewinnen immer mehr
einfluss
die muss die regierung setzt
islamistische attentäter auf freien fuß
die scharia soll größere geltung
bekommen frauenrechte sollen beschnitten
und das öffentliche leben noch stärker
islamisiert werden militante islamisten
rufen zum heiligen krieg auf ägypten
scheint auf dem weg in einen radikal
islamischen staat
der arabische frühling verwandelt sich
in einen arabischen winter kriege in
syrien libyen und dem jemen gehören zu
seinem schrecklichen erbe
syriens präsident baschar al-assad galt
einmal als liberaler hoffnungsträger der
westen hofiert ihn aber er entpuppt sich
als gewaltherrscher als die regime in
tunesien und ägypten gestürzt werden
wagen sich die menschen in syrien im
märz 2011 auf die straße auch hier
wollen die demonstranten freiheit würde
und wirtschaftlichen fortschritt
aber das regime assad isoliert die
aufständischen sowie in diesem
stadtviertel von holmes einem zentrum
des aufstands müll liegt auf den straßen
das wasser ist abgestellt
die gefahr von seuchen wächst 2011
hungern die menschen in homs
wir essen nur reis und das nicht mal
jeden tag ist dass das bafa regie bringt
unsere kinder um tötet unsere
geschwister ist dass seine regierung das
leid der bevölkerung alarmiert die söhre
die im exil leben
auch die aktivistin sie mit rabbo die
das land jahre zuvor unter politischem
druck verlassen hatte sie vernetzt die
opposition im in und ausland
das regime führt von anfang an krieg
gegen sein eigenes volk
das ist kein bürgerkrieg denn ein
bürgerkrieg setzt voraus dass sich
mehrere parteien gegenseitig bekämpfen
im fall von syrien ist es das regime
gegen das volk das nennt man terrorismus
des staates gegen sein eigenes volk
dieses brutale vorgehen us stößt in
seiner eigenen armee auf widerstand
wenige monate nach beginn der aufstände
im sommer 2011 desertieren vor allem
sunnitische soldaten massenhaft und
solidarisieren sich mit den
aufständischen
große teile syriens werden innerhalb von
wenigen monaten zum kampfgebiet
städte veröden die menschen fliehen
scharenweise in die nachbarländer wie
den libanon oder die türkei später nach
europa zehn jahre nach dem beginn der
revolution sind von 12 millionen
menschen der hälfte der syrischen
bevölkerung 6 millionen
binnenflüchtlinge
die anderen sechs millionen sind ins
ausland geflogen
die uno nennt das die größte humanitäre
katastrophe des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts assad ist für all das
verantwortlich doch bis heute erkennt er
die existenz einer opposition nicht an
assad gegner scheitern an einer
gemeinsamen strategie
manche kämpfer wollen demokratische
reformen
andere verfolgen islamistische ziele in
das machtvakuum stößt die terror miliz
des sogenannten islamischen staates und
erobert 2014 weite teile syriens der esc
tausende freiwillige aus dem ganzen
arabischen raum an und aus europa
seit 2014 kontrolliert der es das rad
gebiet von aleppo bis falludscha und
fast bis nach bagdad zu seiner hochburg
wird racker im verlauf des jahres
erobert der es auch mossul und tikrit
dann weitet er seine einflusszonen in
syrien und im irak aus die
geländegewinne des esm irak und syrien
finden vor der haustür der türkei an
ihrer südgrenze stadt flüchtlinge
strömen ins land dschihadisten nutzen
istanbul als durchgangsstation auf dem
weg in den krieg
die türkei muss sich positionieren der
heutige präsident der türkei recep
tayyip erdogan will die unruhen des
arabischen frühlings nutzen und seinen
einfluss in der region ausweiten
er träumt wohl von einer großmacht
türkei die wie im neunzehnten
jahrhundert den arabischen raum
dominiert offiziell lehnt erdogan den
terror des es ab tatsächlich aber lässt
er ihn im stillen gewähren denn in
syrien stehen sich der e s und die
kurden gegenüber für den machtstrategen
erdogan gilt der feind meines feindes
ist mein freund
das verhältnis zwischen der türkei und
den sogenannten islamischen staates ist
ein taktisches gewesen denn ich denke
nicht dass die türkei den es absichtlich
mit aufbauen wollte aber es war eine
kosten nutzen abwägung man wusste wenn
man den es bekämpft dann könnte das
möglicherweise den kurdischen kräften in
die hände spielen und deren bekämpfung
die verhinderung von deren
unabhängigkeit das war die preußen
politische priorität der türkei aber die
kurdischen streitkräfte sind im kampf
gegen den esr volk reich unterstützt
werden sie dabei von frankreich und vor
allem den usa mit waffen und
luftschlägen auf stellungen des die
syrischen kurden stehen der pkk nahe dem
militanten arm der türkischen kurden
international gilt die pkk als
terrorgruppe
doch für die usa steht der kampf gegen
den es im vordergrund unter großen
verlusten vertreiben die kurdischen
milizen denise aus der region auch mit
hilfe von frauen einheiten
die türkei muss hinnehmen dass die
kurden in nordsyrien die autonome region
rosa war ausrufen
zum ersten mal bot sich ein
realistisches szenario dass dort ein
kurdisches autonomiegebiet oder
möglicherweise sogar ein kurdischer
staat entstehen könnte das hat aber die
interessen der türkei im kern berührt
und deswegen hat erdogan seine gesamte
nahost politik seine gesamte politik
gegen will dagegen bei der arabischen
welt nur noch dieser frage untergeordnet
auf jeden fall das entstehen eines
kurdischen staates an der südgrenze der
türkei zu verhindern
die türkei droht nach syrien
einzumarschieren um die kurden zu
bekämpfen und ruft damit syriens
diktator assad auf den plan
er fürchtet eine dauerhafte türkische
besetzung syrischen territoriums und
hält ein kurdisches autonomiegebiet für
das kleinere übel ersatz verbündeter
russland will vor allem den rivalen
türkei in die schranken weisen
dennoch kann erdogan einen teilsieg
feiern
der russische präsident putin lässt so
dass die türkei im norden syriens
pufferzonen einrichtet das schicksal
syriens liegt schon lange nicht mehr in
den händen ab 2017 wird mossul nach
langen kämpfen von der herrschaft des
befreit
hier planten die dschihadisten die
eroberung der muslimischen welt
ihrem schreckens regime fallen
zehntausende zum opfer auch zahlreiche
jesiden angehörige einer kleinen
glaubensgemeinschaft die im norden des
irak lebt das wird erst nach der
zerschlagung des es richtig klar
archiv ja so ein führer der jesiden kann
bis heute nicht verstehen warum europa
und die usa den us gewähren ließen in
einer leichenhalle in bagdad sind 104
särge aufgebahrt überreste von es opfern
aus massengräbern
[Musik]
naja so hat seinen bruder und seinen
neffen bei dem massaker verloren der s
kommt 2014 in das dorf seines bruders
frauen und mädchen werden entführt viele
von ihnen sind bis heute verschollen
männer und jungen werden vor die wahl
gestellt sich zum islam zu bekennen oder
zu sterben innerhalb weniger tage töten
die es terroristen tausende löschen zwei
dörfer aus und verschaffen die leichen
ist doch mein bruder dem ich immer so
nah war
und die anderen sind meine kinder
[Musik]
jahrelang wissen die familien nicht was
mit ihren angehörigen geschehen ist
[Musik]
nach der zerschlagung des konnten einige
jesiden in ihre dörfer zurückkehren
dort fanden sie die massengräber nativ
ja so hat die suche vorangetrieben
niemand hat den massenmord an den juden
verhindern können
vielleicht ist die umbettung der opfer
ein erster schritt das unrecht an den
hiesigen aufzuarbeiten
[Musik]
zurück nach ägypten ins jahr 2013
seit einem jahr ist mohammed mursi
präsident die wirtschaftliche und
politische situation stagniert die
regierung der muslimbrüder hat keine
spürbare verbesserung gebracht
jetzt gehen die menschen wieder auf die
straße diesmal gegen den neu gewählten
präsidenten demokratische freiheiten
mühsam gegen mubarak erkämpft sind
wieder in gefahr
frauen fürchten um ihre rechte die
sharia soll grundlage der rechtsprechung
werden nur sie will die verfassung
ändern und das amt des präsidenten mit
viel mehr macht ausstatten um sich
unangreifbar zu machen
die spannungen auf der straße nehmen
weiter zu
auch safwat el sayed demonstriert wieder
die große dummheit der muslimbrüder
sie versuchten alles abzuschaffen was
ihnen nicht passt
das beste beispiel war der versuch muss
es die verfassung so zu ändern dass die
entscheidungen des präsidenten also
seiner nicht anfechtbar sein sollten
das war eine katastrophe das war gegen
den willen des volkes das war gegen die
demokratiebewegung im sommer 2013
versammeln sich wieder hunderttausende
auf dem tahrir platz diesmal um mosleys
rücktritt zu erzwingen
er ist gerade ein jahr im amt armee
hubschrauber überfliegen den platz
signalisieren unterstützung für die
gegner matisse wie schon beim sturz
mubaraks zeigt das militär wer
tatsächlich die macht in ägypten hat der
mann des militärs in der regierung ist
verteidigungsminister general abdel
fatah als sie als das militär sicher ist
große teile des volkes auf seiner seite
zu haben
pusht als easy und lässt messi und
andere regierungsmitglieder inhaftieren
die kurze herrschaft der muslimbrüder
ist vorbei mohammed mursi wird 2009 10
in der haft sterben
die anhänger der muslimbrüder begehren
gegen den militärputsch auf das regime
antwortet brutal
[Musik]
tausende werden erschossen wandern in
die gefängnisse viele werden in
schnellverfahren zum tod verurteilt die
muslimbrüder zahlen einen hohen blutzoll
nachdem dieser politische konkurrent
ausgeschaltet ist machen die generäle
mit als sie einen der ihren zum
regierungschef
das ende des arabischen frühlings in
ägypten ein exodus setzt ein
tausende die politisch aktiv waren
verlassen das land auch safwat el sayed
2017 flieht er nach berlin
das als easy regime macht keinen
unterschied zwischen politischen gegnern
und verfolgt muslimbrüder genauso wie
demokratische oppositionelle
sie ist mein persönlicher feind eines
exils in deutschland wählen um einer
verlorenen jahre wählen um einer in
ägypten verstorbenen mutter willen von
der ich mich nicht verabschieden und ihr
die letzte ehre erweisen konnte um jedes
exilanten willen und meiner freunde
wählen die im gefängnis sind und dort
schuldlos ihre schönsten jungen
lebensjahre verlieren anfängen der
medizinischen unterversorgung sterben
das was zwischen uns und als sie ist das
ist blöd lange jahre blieb der libanon
von den blutigen unruhen des arabischen
frühlings weitgehend verschont die
finanzmetropole barrage in fast wie eine
oase in den kriegswirren in der syrer
wie golf araber ihre gelder in
immobilien anlegten keine seite hatte
interesse den libanon zu destabilisieren
denn die furcht vor einem übergreifen
des krieges aus dem nachbarland syrien
war groß beirut ist nur zwei autostunden
von damaskus entfernt
jede veränderung galt als riskant im
libanon herrscht ein strenges religiöses
proporzsystem christen sunniten und
schiiten haben das land nach dem ende
des bürgerkriegs 1989 unter sich
aufgeteilt
was einst der befriedung des landes
diente führt heute zur erstarrung
vetternwirtschaft und korruption
die journalistin kim gatters rechnet
auch in ihrem heimatland libanon mit
einem aufstand
er kommt aber mit verspätung jedes land
in der region kämpft seine eigenen
internen kämpfe es hat seine eigene
dynamik aber es ist auch alles
miteinander verbunden es ist teil eines
größeren systems die arabischen
aufstände fanden statt aber der libanon
war zunächst nicht teil dieser welle
das passierte erst 2019 mit den
protesten die im oktober stattfanden und
das ganze jahr 2020 andauerten
im sommer 2009 10 versammeln sich in
beirut wochen lang tausende zu protesten
ist das der beginn eines zweiten
arabischen frühlings die aufstände im
libanon sind teil eines größeren ganzen
sie sind teil des allgemeinen aufstandes
gegen ungerechtigkeit korruption und
unterdrückung
aber dann gibt es die lokale dynamik
spezifisch für den libanon
weil wir hier schiitische milizen haben
die es weder in ägypten noch tunesien
gibt im libanon stellt sich die
schiitische hisbollah den demonstranten
entgegen
die miliz wurde in den kämpfen gegen die
israelische besetzung des südlibanon für
viele libanesen zum mythos
sie kämpfte in syrien und hielt
präsident assad an der macht gesteuert
und finanziert wird die hisbollah aus
iran
inzwischen stellt sie in der
libanesischen regierung auch minister
die hisbollah präsentierte sich immer
als diejenige die für die rechte der
unterdrückten für die armen für die
besetzten kämpfte aber dann traten sie
in die politik ein
und die politik korrumpiert sogar
widerstandsbewegungen so sehen das viele
menschen im libanon die hisbollah war
teil des korrupten establishments
geworden
die folgen dieser korruption erleben die
libanesen im sommer 2020 eine
gigantische explosion erschüttert beirut
das gesamte viertel um den hafen ist
zerstört dutzende sterben hunderte sind
schwer verletzt
[Musik]
es wird sich herausstellen dass fast
3000 tonnen ammoniumnitrat seit jahren
ungeschützt im hafen lagerten
das hochentzündliche pulver explodiert
vermutlich wegen schweißarbeiten symbol
für das versagen des staates der seine
bürger nicht schützt
die menschen müssen sich selbst kümmern
die zivilgesellschaft ersetzt den staat
private hilfsorganisationen wie die
gemeinnützige dafa versorgen die opfer
der explosion mit dem nötigsten
borna jacobi an leitet die
hilfsorganisation
sie zeigt an der wand karte welche
verwüstungen die explosion angerichtet
hat
paul jacobi an hat ihr parlamentsmandat
aus protest gegen die grassierende
korruption niedergelegt
[Musik]
die tickende bombe wurde vor unserer
nase in beirut platziert die regierung
der präsident sie alle wussten von dem
ammonium in beirut und sie taten nichts
wir vertrauten dem christlichen führer
dass er christ und dem sunniten dass er
ein sunnit ist und dem schiiten
sie haben nichts mit gott zu tun sie
sind ein haufen von teufeln die
versuchen ein armes land zu regieren
ein gespaltenes land niemand fühlte sich
dafür verantwortlich dass im hafen
sprengmaterial frei herum lag keine der
politisch religiösen gruppierungen ohne
deren genehmigung im libanon nichts
geschieht
ich wünsche mir ein land in dem ein sohn
zur schule gehen und in sicherheit
zurückkommen kann ich wünsche mir ein
land in dem der saubere luft atmen
können sauberes wasser haben eine
wirtschaft und eine zukunft haben in der
jeder frei ist zu denken was er will
jeder ist frei sich so zu kleiden wie er
will
ich meine wir kämpfen immer noch für
unsere grundbedürfnisse nach der
explosion gehen die proteste zwar weiter
aber die menschen haben nur wenig
hoffnung auf veränderung wer kann
verlässt das land auch im libanon lassen
sich die machthaber nicht vertreiben
aber es gibt hoffnung trotz allem etwa
in mossul große teile der nordirakischen
stadt sind 2017 bei den kämpfen zwischen
dem s und der irakischen armee
unterstützt von der us-luftwaffe dem
erdboden gleichgemacht worden der es
wurde vernichtend geschlagen
jetzt scheint der weg frei für einen
neuanfang
[Musik]
najem al dschuburi hat als hoher
offizier auf seiten der irakischen armee
gekämpft jetzt ist er gouverneur der
provinz und für den wiederaufbau modules
zuständig
die bewaffneten gruppierungen machen wir
sorgen
sie tauchen immer wieder auf obwohl die
öffentliche stimmung sehr stark gegen
sie ist ich prangere sie immer
öffentlich an und ich bekämpfe sie auch
die sicherheitslage ist angespannt
bodyguards begleitet den gouverneur auf
schritt und tritt
der gang durch den basar gehört zu
seinem alltag
er will vertrauen schaffen sich nicht
abschotten die leute sollen merken dass
sich jemand um sie kümmert
das zahlt sich aus der gouverneur gilt
als beliebt in seiner mischung aus sorge
und strenge
bitte halten sie sich an den abstand zum
durchgang
sonst lassen wir ihren stamm schließen
das auftreten des gouverneurs und
ehemaligen militärs scheint die leute zu
beeindrucken
najem al dschuburi hat den ruf kein
bestechliche politiker zu sein
das macht ihn im irak wohl zu einer
ausnahme ich finde keine arbeit genauso
wie 2000 andere männer dabei sind der
gute bauarbeiter warum werden wir nicht
bei den aufräumarbeiten eingesetzt dafür
sind die bauunternehmen zuständig die
bauunternehmen die bauunternehmen hier
haben sie gute arbeitskräfte vor ort
lasst uns in zukunft arbeiter aus der
gegend einsätzen keine türkischen
arbeiter lehrern aber die arbeit muss
auch ordentlich erledigt werden ich gebe
ihnen brief und siegel ich werde mir das
anschauen
sie können sich auf uns verlassen die
zukunft des irak entscheidet sich vor
allem an der frage ob die jugend des
landes eine perspektive bekommt damit
wir die quellen des terrors im irak und
anderen ländern austrocknen und er es
und andere terroristische organisationen
nicht wiederkommen müssen die
europäische gemeinschaft und die ganze
welt den regionen die unter demenz
gelitten haben zur seite steht
wir müssen das denken nachhaltig
verändert auch die wirtschaftliche
situation muss sich verbessern das ist
sehr wichtig wenn es hier wirtschaftlich
bergab geht bietet das wieder ein umfeld
in das sich der terror einschleichen
kann
zwischen chaos und wiederaufbau was ist
das erbe des arabischen frühlings in
libyen syrien und jemen toben seit
jahren bürgerkriege die sich zu
internationalen konflikten ausgeweitet
haben
in ägypten hat das militär die macht
übernommen dessen repräsentant als cc
herrscht heute härter als vor der
revolution in saudi arabien bahrain und
kuwait gelang es den herrschenden regime
an den status quo zu erhalten
in marokko jordanien und den oman
reagierten die königshäuser auf die
begrenzten proteste mit begrenzten
reformen in algerien libanon und dem
irak flammen immer wieder proteste auf
bislang ohne die herrschende politische
klasse vertreiben zu können
im sudan haben die proteste zu einem
regierungswechsel geführt
nur in tunesien konnte sich die
revolution behaupten mit einer neuen
verfassung kommt es zu friedlichen
machtwechseln
tunesien gilt als erfolgsmodell des
arabischen frühlings in der verfassung
sind rechtsstaatlichkeit und
gleichberechtigung festgeschrieben
aber die wirtschaftlichen probleme des
landes sind enorm das bildungsniveau ist
hoch es gibt viele hochschulabsolventen
aber kaum arbeit
die wenigen jobs gehen vor allem an
männer die jungen frauen bleiben außen
vor
noch ballett league ist eine große
ausnahme
sie ist bürgermeisterin von bucher einem
dorf an der küste
es begann damit dass ich auf meinem
rückweg von der uni nach hause über den
markt laufen musste und dabei fiel mir
auf dass es nur männer auf dem markt gab
ich konnte keine einzige frau finden
dann habe ich mir gesagt sobald ich mit
meinem studium fertig bin werde ich
versuchen diese situation zu verändern
ich habe immer daran geglaubt wenn jeder
sagt das interessiert mich nicht warum
soll ich damit anfangen dann bleibt
buchara so wie es ist
[Musik]
erhältlich ist die jüngste
bürgermeisterin tunesiens die fischer im
dorf lehnten sie erst ab sie sollen sich
etwas von einer so jungen frau sagen
lassen aber inzwischen reden sie
wenigstens mit ihr ballett league stammt
aus einer religiösen familie ihr vater
ist immer auch er hat inzwischen
akzeptiert dass sie in der
öffentlichkeit auftritt
sie will ein vorbild sein ich hatte
immer motivation und leidenschaft und
wollte was nach der revolution tun
ja warum kann ich nicht an der
öffentlichen arbeit teilnehmen
warum kann ich nicht die frau in dem
drama sein
die rausgeht und mit den männern
arbeitet damit wollte ich auch die
frauen motivieren damit sie machen was
ich gemacht habe
[Musik]
inzwischen folgen einige frauen dem
beispiel von ballett league
vielleicht ist die arbeit an der basis
der einzige weg um langfristige
veränderungen zu erreichen
das streben nach freiheit nach
gerechtigkeit nach würde ist in der
region nicht vorbei viele leute benutzen
den begriff arabischer frühling um zu
beschreiben was im dezember 2010 in
tunesien mit visa sie begann dem
gemüsehändler der würde wollte er wollte
einen job er wollte ein einkommen aber
er wollte auch würde er wollte als
bürger respektiert werden als
menschliches wesen und das geschah
überall in tunesien und ägypten und
syrien mit einigen erfolgen hier und
schrecklichen misserfolgen dort aber ich
denke dass die aufstände weitergehen
es ist eine andauernde suche nach einer
besseren zukunft
der arabische frühling hat die länder
nordafrikas und des nahen ostens für
immer verändert die menschen haben
erfahren dass herrscher gestürzt werden
können
viele haben das chaos der revolutionen
mit ihrem leben bezahlt und trotzdem
kämpfen andere weiter dafür in einer
gerechteren gesellschaft zu leben
der arabische frühling mark vorbei sein
aber sein erbe lebt weiter
[Musik]